alors à toi si la
main
tactiquement dans la cabine téléphonique
est sûre c'est parce que
tu move le jeu je viens vous arrive est
grave pourquoi tu t'es comme tu le fais
exprès je vois bien que je téléphone tu
viens bloqué rapport mais je travaille
elle c'est pas une raison au lendemain
du soutien je travaille nos cerveaux la
construction d'un hall à la
63e et nomao à l'eau à temps mais pas
pour longtemps hélas pour une heure au
nom et lamoise est sorti non non c'est
pas possible
parce qu'il n'a pas bloqué
si rien ne
bloque
c'est l'europe ouais c'est bloqué non
non non non alors quand on arrête un
signal qui va tomber toi moi maintenant
à rousies habana ah non amano
attention quand j'en ai pour deux
secondes nous condamnons
tout aspect cool tu m'as l'année attend
de ce que je remets la vispa n'y a pas
qu'à spa les couilles des centres
ça y est la cie n'ont certes pas où j'en
ai rien à [ __ ]
de sandra oh dis non
voilà sinon ça bloque la porte graine
rien à [ __ ] tout blanc c'est tout un
sport à west est
hélas ouais c'est l'agglo
et la l1 sur bois hélas hélas
à les revoir
[Musique]